what's up it's your boy kfc from
barstool sports for the last seven years
we've been doing our podcast kfc radio
answering the weirdest questions the
internet has to offer and now we're
putting celebrities and comedians to the
test this is answer the internet today's
episode is brought to you by postmates
anything you want anytime you want it
postmate it download the postmates app
use promo code kfc for a hundred dollars
off your delivery charge for the next
seven days that's promo code kfc for a
hundred dollars off delivery charge for
the next seven days i'm francis ellis
and this is answer the internet thrilled
to be here obviously i'll be at the
wilbur theater this friday may 17th
taping my first stand-up special hope
you'll be there as well
would you rather watch your dad have sex
with a 100 year old man
or watch your mom kill someone
it would be really tough for my dad uh
he's uh he's impotent
um due to uh uh he had his uh
he had a surgical procedure that they
cut too big of a swath
around his um prostate so he can't get
erections anymore
um so that's out of out of bounds
i don't know that i think my mom could
kill someone as opposed to
my dad with the slinky noodle
so i'd rather watch my mom for the sake
of reality i'd like to watch my mom kill
someone and she would too she's a feisty
one first class of women at princeton
there you go
uh would you rather kill 25 kittens in a
row or one dog absolutely
kittens unless it were a pit bull um
i mean let's be honest their
their maniac
ravage savage machines of death with
their gnashing teeth and their
bloodthirsty eyes they're all possessed
and you can't teach a pit bull new
tricks or whatever
and so i don't know 25 kittens i don't
like cats but i mean we all know
pitbulls like
that's why i was such a mike vick fan
anybody that kills a pit bull is a
friend of mine so um
that's he's a hero uh
in that regard
one pit bull
any other species 25 kittens
here's a classic for you i'm gonna get
in trouble for that
you get 100 000 to put your baby in a
microwave for three seconds dude do it
uh
yeah
absolutely
um you can put the milk in there with it
bring that up to room temperature i'm
like
depending on what setting you put it on
you know if you're just like reheat
baked potato baby's gonna be fine
if it's like full nuke
uh that baby's probably in trouble
um but uh yeah 100 grand come on
that's a lot of money it's a lot of
formula
uh private school for at least a year so
no no brainer
for the baby
uh would you rather watch your parents
have sex every night or join in one time
to make it stop
god you know it would become uh like a
thing for us something we could like
enjoy
um
it wouldn't be weird after i don't know
10 viewings
um
and i think me joining in is is so
perverse it's so incestuous
and we'd never recover from that but
again
i don't know what my dad's doing because
he can't get hard so
maybe in that regard like if it were my
dad and me
you know
fisting my mom together
or or possibly one of us wearing a strap
on that's not so bad
if we're not both in her
so
yeah uh if you could upgrade one body
part what would it be
biceps
honestly um it's a sore subject for me
i've always been a little bit uh
sort of
very uh
what's the word i feel insecure about my
biceps my thighs and my calves are
incredibly thunderous and defined no
matter how much upper body work i do the
buys don't come out
so definitely the biceps everything else
is pretty good
look at me i'm symmetrical if there were
stats available for every aspect of your
life what three stats would you want to
see
um
i want to know the ratio of
real orgasms i've delivered versus fake
orgasms
i would want to know how many women i
who faked it with me
because
there were some where i was like you're
so full of [__] i've taken acting
classes like stella adler give me a
[__] break
this is [__] your lips aren't
quivering you're not even sweating those
those sighs came so close together
nobody contracts like that the vagina
doesn't manifest through the mouth that
way um [__] you you're lying to me
you're lying to my face don't talk to me
again and we didn't um
but
i do think there were definitely some
that fooled me and i'd like to know who
those women were so i could have another
crack
at uh at them there are two buttons one
instantly gives you a million dollars
and one gives you 50 50 shot
at a mill at 100 million
ah which do you push
i mean you guys know me financially
that's
one million dollars
it's like that's like a week or two from
mom and dad uh so it's gonna be the 50
50 shot at 100 million that's
life-changing money to me million
dollars
yeah that's not it's not going to move
the needle right yeah
like
one year the golf course uh
if you could pick in a new bag and a new
bag i could get new irons and pay my
dues
if you could pick one celebrity to have
your back in a bar fight who would you
pick jason momoa
yeah aquaman and i'll tell you why um i
met him
uh out in sundance at the sundance film
festival his team of handlers and his
posse thought i was someone i wasn't
they thought i was someone important
some publicist from hollywood they
invited me to brunch at a hotel and we
uh we went to the waffle station
together and that was where they figured
out i wasn't the person that they had
assumed i was and from that point on
they were still very nice to me and he's
super jacked he throws uh tomahawks
which you know it has to be an outdated
technology but even then he's somebody i
would be like ah this guy this guy knows
how to pull people
uh and
whatever destroy them if you had the
chance to have sex with your dream girl
but you have to do it in front of her
family would you do it absolutely
what if they are watching through a
double-sided mirror i mean come on like
my dream girl i don't need to know that
we're gonna get married and that's why
you would need to impress her parents or
maintain a good
relationship with them and if they're
watching that's more on them
right that's not on me like if my dream
girl's family just happens to be
incredibly voyeuristic
and as a family they assemble and
masturbate standing up on the other side
of a mirror like that guy from saw
uh
that's on them and we're not gonna be
getting married because her family does
that
but we'll get
we'll we'll have sex
one time
and i would i'd make it nasty too i'd
come all over her oh
no for for them for them
that's what they want they're into that
and you have to give them that shower
would you rather be the president the
pope or the ruler of north korea north
korea is the obvious answer here and um
the reason is you don't have to abide by
the rule of law
you're above the law there is no law you
define the law the ruler of north korea
it has been rumored to have a harem of
like 28 wives women
people whatever
people that will taste his food to make
sure it's not poisoned he can do
whatever he wants pope still has to
kind of like abide by
you know
people law
and then the president is obviously
you know
not responsive what is one rumor true or
false you'd want spread about yourself
i think it'd be cool if everyone spread
the rumor that i was in the military
but
i didn't
so i'm not committing
stolen valor everyone else is
perpetuating it on my behalf
and if the rumor becomes so ubiquitous
that it's accepted as truth
then i never really have to corroborate
it i don't have to say that if people
are like let's talk about the time you
spent you know in the gulf i'll be like
ah you know i don't like to talk about
that
that's not a lie
i've always wanted to be in the military
or
have have served and then enjoy
the discounts on veterans day and things
like that at the mall i'm sure the
internet will just they'll be cool i
have a lot of respect for the military
yeah
you've always wanted like the uh
the third inning like salute yeah
yeah i always wanted you know to to have
dress blues without the ptsd
it's the cake without the preparation
it's like i want
you know i want to go to those dinners
that they have where everyone gets up
and speaks
uh kate and chaps do i want to be on
zero blog 30
and just talk about our time
that we did you know
um
without having without having done it
yeah but but again i don't want to
actually fight because it's
scary
uh would you rather have half your teeth
or half your hair
hair for sure um is the right answer um
teeth you can't
you're missing teeth
that's that's tough uh unless you're
like a pirate or an old woman
who sews
stuff like works in like one of those uh
arts and crafts stores in weird
cottage industries there's a charm
there's a charm that comes for nhl
players
with missing a few of their front teeth
and they're given status as like
warriors who went through hell
but the reality is for a normal person
if you haven't
well you've been to war
there you go
your word's not mine
would you rather come loudly every time
you fart or fart loudly every time you
come i love this question
would you rather come loudly every time
you fart
or fart loudly every time
you come i like come loudly every time
you fart because
um
you can
you can drop these silent but deadly
farts
and wear a diaper
like a slim fit diaper and you're
talking about potentially
dozens of orgasms throughout the day
where you know i've i've done i've had
i've had or i've come
and tried to make nobody know like in
houses with thin walls where parents
were around stuff like that
and uh so i can put that face on i can
do that thing and um
uh
and then you know you if you were like
feeling particularly
horny you could just
bring it up go eat taco bell and then
blow your dick off you know that'd be
kind of fun
all day long
would you rather your mom or your sister
be a porn star
so
my mom is like 67
and at this point that's
moving into guilf
territory
um
and
i don't think anyone really wants to
watch that
so i know my sister would be better at
it
she would be more successful and my
thought is like if both of them have the
opportunity to delve into porn
i would hope that they'd at least be
successful at it does that make sense
there's nothing the only thing worse
than having a sister who's in porn is
having a sister who's in porn who sucks
at it who's kind of like struggling at
porn it's like ah you know i'm getting
i'm only getting like three scenes a
week and uh it's always a 12-man
interracial gang bang i'm really not
getting booked for the one-on-one
sex scenes with the handsome guy
i have to take 12 dicks it's like well
you know keep trying
and you'll get there it's just you know
you need to lose some weight and get
some some work done
that's that would suck
so for that regard
you know what i mean like if your
sister's in porn you want wouldn't you
rather that she's like a celebrity and
known for every question
rather than your sister being good or
bad
yeah so um
i think the answer is sister because
she's far more likely to be successful
than my mom you look at the girl from
girls do porn the one who
um the miss
one of the miss
wasn't the co it was the other one
delaware miss delaware she only she's
only done one porn scene as far as i can
tell right
and it was so bad
that nobody ever asked her to come back
that to me is a fate worse than being
a brilliant
you know avn winning porn star who can
then move into directing once gravity
affects your breasts too much and like
that is
to to be able to just do one porn star
and suck at to do one pointy and suck
and then never be asked back that like
because you're still getting hit with
that i did a porn scene and that now
it's about to be yours just to bring
your family shame yeah elvis family they
can't even [__] yeah
yeah
like she tried the one thing
that the one job you can still be
available for
regardless of
being incarcerated
regardless of how many teeth or hair you
have tattoos they're taking everybody
that's an open application and she still
failed where do you go from there
would you have a threesome with kelly
ripa
and regis philbin
uh
sure
regis
you know we'll do the old
merry-go-rounds you ready swap
i think
eiffel towering kelly refo with with
regis would be pretty funny because i
feel like he'd get it wrong you know
he'd like interlock fingers and try to
hold it i'm like buddy it's just
an instant thing
and then let's not touch after that
um would you rather go to jail for one
year or go to jail with a rubik's cube
and you can leave when it's done
yeah rubik's cube for me for sure
because i have a general sense of how
it's supposed to go people have shown me
the steps i think i understand the
general arrangement i trust my brain to
sort that out ahead like well ahead of a
year i mean come on thanks for having me
wilbur theater friday may 17th uh come
see me i'm taping my standup special
thank you so much